he's the MVP of the National Football
League the reigning MVP of the National
Football League who took care of
business last night on Sunday Night
Football against a fellow former MVP of
the NFL and Aaron Rodgers and the Green
Bay Packers he is of the 200 Falcons
joining us Matt Ryan he back here on the
Rich Eisen show how you doing Matt I'm
doing great thanks for having me on
thank you for thanks for calling in
after such a big Sunday night game what
did you guys see on film against Green
Bay that you thought you could exploit
exploit when you got out on the field
against them on Sunday yeah I think the
biggest thing when we watch the Seattle
game was just that there was a
commitment to stop the run from the
Green Bay defense and playing a lot more
single safety coverage than we had seen
from them last year and you know we felt
like our play-action passing game could
could open some things up for us earlier
in the game it certainly did that we
created some explosives and and also you
know created some run opportunities for
us I thought we ran the ball really well
last night well from just the
perspective of sitting on a couch it
sure looks like you guys picked up where
you last left off last year how do you
read it Matt well you know I think we're
doing some good things for sure you know
the first drive last night for us felt
like we got into a really good rhythm
which kind of you know got the ball
rolling for us in that game specifically
in the first half I do think there's a
lot of things we can clean up we're not
where we need to be yet you know but
it's good to be two games into it with
two wins and still a lot of room for
improvement so then I'd like to run
through some narratives that have been
placed upon the Falcons going into the
season by the national media and
certainly I'm sure you've heard it
locally Matt and I'd like you to go one
by one here if you don't mind starting
with the fact that your old offensive
coordinator is now the coach in San
Francisco and you and Steve Sarkisian
wouldn't have that simpatico
relationship right from Jump Street and
it would affect the offense what do you
say to that well you know I think we're
we're you know getting more comfortable
together for sure you know but we've
done a good job the first two weeks and
I think we'll continue to improve on on
on that front it's never easy when you
have a change at that position at that
coaching spot
it's it's there's just everybody's a
little bit different but Steve's been
easy to work with and you know certainly
done a great job for us the first weeks
well how do you do how do you get on
that page that same page other than just
playing football games well that's the
most important thing I think as we
continue to play games and we're in the
the fire together I think that's how you
really connect but communication I mean
open lines of communication is key
that's something that I've learned
throughout my career is to really
communicate clearly with your
coordinator the things that you're
seeing and then vice versa they need to
to really communicate clearly to you
what their expectation is so is today a
day for that yeah absolutely you know I
think Monday and Tuesday following you
know following a game is critical for
for a quarterback and a coordinator
specifically you know early on working
together I think as you get further into
the relationship there's a better
understanding of each other but early on
that communication is key you know post
game so just getting just a little bit
deeper in the weeds on this do you have
a list of things from last night that
you're gonna go in today and say hey
Steve XYZ ABC yeah as we watch the film
together for sure there'll be things
that that we talked about today of Davis
came up in the second quarter or this
came up in the third quarter what were
you thinking here what here's what I was
thinking here here's where you know you
could help me out with this or here's
where I can help you out with that
those are definitely things that come up
and and as I watched the film first
myself but also you know I usually have
a mental checklist of things that we
need to talk about the day after as you
got one for me from last night give you
any nuggets no gets because chick-fil-a
is not open on a Sunday that is true
that is true and I talked about it
because NFL Network has the Thursday
night game where it's the only night in
that new stadium chick-fil-a will be
open man you go I've gotta get some
Nuggets for me I've got a
come to town for that to happen before
we get to the new stadium I do want to
hit another narrative and that is
anytime there is a moment of adversity
Super Bowl fifty one is gonna crop up in
the mind's eye of everybody in the
organization what do you say to
something about that Matt well you know
I think that narrative is outside the
building for sure that's a question that
we've had to answer and I think we all
have answered you know is there as a any
you know residual effect of that I can
speak for for our locker room and the
guys in our locker room you know we're
not thinking about that you know our
guys are focused on on how good this
27-foot 2017 football team can become
and you know we've answered that and
talked about that and that's honestly
that's that's how we feel you know
that's what we're focused on and so we
understand that we're gonna have to
answer questions about that that's
that's the nature of our business but
inside this building I think we have the
right mindset no I did see on NFL
gameday morning uh my pregame show with
the guys on NFL Network yesterday you
carrying some monster huge log in a
piece that Andrea Kramer did about you
guys working with the Navy SEALs with a
former Navy SEAL in the offseason to get
mentally tough for this exact subject of
conversation that we're having so what
what if what have you guys done Oh about
that yeah I mean that was that was one
of the things Dan had us do during the
off season was was have a group of Navy
SEALs from a company called APG come in
and you know they were guys that we had
worked with before but you know just
from a from a you know a standpoint of
mentally being able to move on to the
next mission or the next opportunity
whatever it may be really there's nobody
better to pick their brains than the
seals and the group of guys that we've
gotten to know the last two years I
think they've really helped our team
with that and you know Karen that log
you know I was always a weak link in our
group I was listen to guys yeah they
were pulling my weight which was nice
but you know it was good it was good for
us and I think it brought our team
probably closer together yeah I mean III
thought to myself I'll be honest I'm
like look I feel I'm a team player and I
understand you know I've got to get
better in my profession every single day
but I'm not lifting a log frame luckily
I was with some offensive linemen and
defensive lines and you have made it a
lot easier for myself Matt Ryan here on
the Rich Eisen show I also noticed that
that Dan Quinn is a clock that instead
of any of the numbers on it it just says
the word now so it's half past now it's
and it's 15 minutes to now is that
another thing that he's done essentially
or to to turn the page or is that clock
always been on the wall man yeah that's
been on the wall since he got here it
makes for you know meeting times what
times things are gonna be a little bit
confusing but you know it's something
that that's his mindset and that's no
different from the first day he stepped
into this building you know he talks
about that all the time the most
important you know day or meeting or
whatever is the one that you're in and
you know it's something that he lives by
and I think it you know it translates
into our team I think a lot of guys have
that mindset so what is it like getting
on the field in a game against somebody
of Aaron Rodgers caliber obviously
you've done it many many times with
other people and I understand that every
game is important but when you step out
on the field and you know that Aaron
Rodgers number 12 at the controls for
the opponent how does that affect the
way you go about your business Matt well
you know that they're always in it
he's he's an unbelievable player and
such a great competitor you know that's
we've gone against each other a number
of times and you know he just makes so
many plays his ability to extend play
scramble and find receivers down the
field is he's as good as anybody ever in
my opinion and you know you just know
going into it that you know regardless
of whatever leads that you have they're
gonna continue to battle and chip away
at and you've got to be sharp for four
quarters and really not give them
anything and that's you know that's
probably good advice for any time you're
playing but certainly when you're going
against a player of his caliber and
obviously you'll be in an interested
observer in Monday Night Football
tonight because
next opponent is the lions how do you do
you a game when you're just watching uh
in real time like the rest of America as
a scout in a way I just enjoy it you
know I'll get to work probably more so
tomorrow on on Detroit and on their
defense but tonight you know I'll just
watch casually it's you know maybe
there's something you could pick up here
there I guess you never really turn that
analytical eye off but for the most part
I'll watch it you know just as a normal
sense well plus you're also tight with
Stafford that I know right you're very
friendly with him and your wives are
friendly absolutely you know he's one of
my you know best friends and a great guy
great competitor you know but it's all
bets off this week well then I know when
that happens and I'm sure it's the same
way for him and then you know he
obviously is the the highest paid
quarterback in the National Football
League right now and you might surpass
that very soon can you just give us an
update on what your contractual
conversations with the Falcons has been
so far Matt yeah I mean there's there's
nothing going on and and you know that's
completely normal for for how we operate
I don't worry about it you know I feel
like you know I take care of my business
on the field and leave the business side
of it to my agents and to the front
office here so you know I think it'll
get done when it needs to get done we've
got plenty of time and you know just I
just got to keep focusing on playing
good football well all you got to do is
just look around the new stadium and
know that the team has the money there
was no shortage of dollar spent on that
stadium Arthur did a great job and I'm
really happy for him you know he
deserves it it's been an incredible you
know ride for me to play for him for as
long as I have and last night to see the
stadium open up and to get a win with
the opener knowing that he has put you
know so much of his life into that
building it was it was really special it
looks incredible on TV I got to tell you
you're gonna love it when you tell NFL
Network to get you down for the Thursday
night dance you can get your Nuggets yes
you're gonna love the stadium it looks
incredible
the way that that roof opens up although
I gotta say this Matt in my end of the
business okay in the television in the
advent of 4k does not help me okay I'm a
man pushing 50 you can wear makeup for a
living 4k doesn't help okay so so I mean
now that when you do a play I mean if
you look up you see it on all these
screens I mean my gosh what do you think
about that Matt you're looking up you
see it everywhere yeah we better get the
nose hair trimmer now or whatever
alright Matt thanks for calling in after
a big win good luck down the line I
already look forward to our next chat
thanks rich appreciate it but that's a
Matt Ryan Falcons quarterback the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy